pro-life pregnancy centers provided at
least $358 million in goods and services
to pregnant women last year that
includes half a million free ultrasounds
at least 200,000 tests for venial
disease 700,000 free pregnancy tests
400,000 parenting education programs
600,000 students who took sexual risk
avoidance education 4.3 million baby
outfits and by the way not just for the
babies and the mothers who chose to have
their children even for the women who
killed their children through abortion
19,000 people received postabortion
support at least probably the number is
much higher than that from pro-life
pregnancy centers and this is a really
good thing because 32,000 more babies
were born last year than the year before
thanks to State abortion bans in the
wake of the do's decision I I tell you I
I kind of like this legislating morality
doesn't it work I kind of like the
notion that culture is Downstream of
politics I kind of like the idea that
the law is a teacher because it works